[Music]
on this Thursday night the cost of
connecting we're just getting gou
Canadian frustration as two of the
country's biggest telecom companies push
prices up even higher the easiest place
to farm revenue is from their own
customers two New Brunswick men cleared
of a murder conviction how do you feel I
feel good the raw motions after 40 Years
of maintaining their
innocence an increase in strep a what to
know about the risk of infection
especially for
kids and the Teen who beat
Tetris oh my God his historic triumph
over one of the most influential video
games of all
[Music]
time global national with Donna freezen
reporting tonight Carolyn
Jarvis good evening and thanks for
joining us as Canadians cope with the
climbing cost of living they're being
dealt another blow
both Rogers and Bell will be raising the
prices of some of their Wireless phone
plans in the weeks ahead as Mackenzie
gray reports in our top story tonight a
lack of competition among major
providers in this country is leaving
customers without many other
options it's a chore that most Canadians
dread we're just getting gouged I
thought when Rogers bought Shaw it was
supposed to bring the cost down and
instead it's brought the costs up way to
go regardless of how old you are you
need to scam them renewing your cell
phone plan just sucks I don't make that
much you guys like and a phone is a
necessity you can't have you can't live
without one and it's likely going to get
worse Roger's customers who aren't
locked into a plan can expect between a
seven and $9 price hike for Bell
customers it's six bucks I'm finally
done 15 years with Roger screw there's
my $7 increase right there Circle price
increases that are even seeing the
experts switch well usually it's $5 a
month it happens every year the easiest
place to farm revenue is from their own
customers so it was inevitable there
would be price increases but dat of the
industry and the liberal government
points to shows sell prices have been
steadily dropping since 2019 plan prices
have sunk on average nearly 14% annually
according to statistics Canada that
fulfills a liberal campaign promise to
cut sell costs by 25% but the cheaper
contracts haven't translated into lower
bills Canadian households have saved
close to only $3 a month between 2019
and 2021 on their cell phone statement
with an average cost of $109 as per
stats can some of the highest prices in
the world the baseline from which those
improvements have been made has been
incredibly weak we're at the bottom of
the international league tables and
relative to what we see in international
countries we still see Canada uh lagging
behind more competition was promised
after Rogers and Shaw merged last year
with freedom mobile being sold to
quebec-based Videotron in a bid to
create a fourth major national provider
but so far that hasn't led to a
significant Market change Canada's
always been afraid and protected itself
from foreign competition in ways that a
lot of other countries don't and those
other countries if there's more
competition of for customers prices
almost certainly go down industry
Minister Francois Philip shampagne said
he would watch telecom companies like a
hawk to increase competition but he
wasn't available Carol
to discuss how that was
going McKenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you emotions ran high inside in Ontario
courtroom today as relatives of a Muslim
family that was murdered in London face
the man responsible a sentencing hearing
for Nathaniel veltman began with what's
expected to be two days worth of Victim
Impact statements from those closest to
the asals the family veltman targeted
with his truck in June of 2021 Global
sha O'Shea was in the London courtroom
today
Sean Carolyn after a 10-week jury trial
that saw Nathaniel veltman found guilty
of first-degree murder this part of the
criminal justice process isn't so much
focused on guilt but on the people left
behind in a 14th floor courtroom here in
London Ontario the families of Nathaniel
veltman's victims along with many others
affected by his actions finally got a
chance to speak the struggle the sense
of fear the
apprehension and lack of Safety and
Security are all real 23-year-old
veltman was convicted on four charges of
first-degree murder in November a jury
found veltman intentionally drove his
pickup truck into the Absol family in
London in June of 2021 veltman admitted
he killed the husband wife daughter and
mother when they were out for a walk
because they were Muslim and now with
the most significant rise of
islamophobia in decades we must unite as
a country against hate they endure a
relentless barrage of discrimination
fueled by ignorance and misinformation
the judge set aside two days for Victim
Impact statements nearly 70 in all close
family members spoke from the witness
box and called The Murders Unthinkable
heartbreaking a senseless act describing
the family members who were killed as
the most lovely friendly Souls who never
harmed anyone you took something
incredibly precious from us one family
member said directly to veltman as he
sat listening you have stolen everything
veltman was stone-faced as family
members spoke some sobbing many talked
about their Newfound fear as Muslims
fear for family members who could be
targets for someone else expressing hate
we must reflect as a nation on how we
ensure that this does not happen ever
again a reason why so many wanted to
speak up in court that it's also about
reclaiming our sense of safety and place
uh in community Through hope through
hope healing and resiliency veltman
faces a mandatory sentence of life in
prison with no chance of parole for 25
years if the judge finds the killings
were a terrorist act he may have to wait
much longer with enough
hatred anything is a weapon and nobody
is safe as for veltman who appeared to
have no supporters in court he'll be
allowed to address the judge if he wants
when he's sentenced later this month
Carolyn sha OA in London Ontario thanks
Shan in Toronto police are investigating
a suspected hate crime after a fire tore
through a jewish-owned grocery store
Wednesday May make no mistake it was a
criminal act that was organized and has
inflicted great harm in our communities
no stone will be left unturned in this
investigation Toronto's police chief has
vowed to find those responsible one day
after the fire broke out and windows
were smashed the grocery store remains
closed the words free Palestine were
spray painted on the
building Ontario's special
investigations unit is looking into the
the death of a 21-year-old woman after
police were called to help but no one
came in time according to the SIU police
in thunderbay received a call about a
domestic disturbance at 2: a.m. December
30th but officers did not respond it
says a second 911 call was made to
cancel the initial one but still no one
came to verify a third call was then
made from the home indicating the woman
Jenna osberg was dead inside only at
that time did officers arrive to
discover her
body two New Brunswick men who spent
years behind bars for a murder they
maintained they did not commit have
finally cleared their names Robert
mailman and Walter gaspie have been
exonerated of second deegree murder and
today walked out of court as innocent
men
no did you ever think in your wildest
dreams this day would would
come you
no their 1984 convictions were
overturned last month by the federal
Justice jce Minister who ordered a new
trial today a judge found them not
guilty Gillespie is 81 years old mailman
is 76 and has terminal cancer Heidi pach
reports on the Justice finally
delivered it's not the first time
they've come here to plead not guilty
how you feeling going in
sir good but this time decades later
they came out overcome by
emotion no
81-year-old Walter Gillespie just heard
a New Brunswick chief justice declare
him and fellow defendant Robert mailman
not guilty after each spent 20 years
behind bars convicted of second deegree
murder no I just like to thank
everybody mailman too weak to stand for
long is 76 years old and has terminal
cancer told in November he had 3 months
to live I can't talk they're glad this
day has finally come they're sorry it's
taken 40 years for it to come the case
dates back to 1983 when George Gilman
Leman was found dead in a wooded area in
St John his body badly beaten partially
burned mailman and gillesby were found
guilty the following year both served
life sentences were paroled after two
decades and innocence Canada made the
case for wrongful conviction to Ottawa
in 2019 in December Federal Justice
Minister Arie fan rescinded their
convictions based on new information
including withheld evidence and
recanting of witness statements the
constellation of factors uh gives rise
to a real concern that not only has
there been a miscarriage of justice but
that two innocent men have been
convicted of a murder they didn't commit
the court proceeding here took just over
30 minutes all this two weeks after the
minister quashed their convictions after
40 Years of fighting as for the police
force that carried out the investigation
all those years ago go they got a lot to
answer for in this case it's a disgrace
the St John police force only responding
it will be seeking the final results of
the Department of Justice's review of
the case and rationale that led to
today's outcome let's get W to as
Gillespie and mailman now prepare to
live the rest of their lives as innocent
men Heidi pic Global News St John New
Brunswick there are continued fears
tonight the spillover from the fighting
in Gaza will spread across the Middle
East and today the US dispatched its top
Diplomat Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin to ease the tension Jackson prco
reports in the south of Gaza the place
Palestinians were told to go for their
own safety Israeli shelling killed 16
including nine children according to the
Gaza Health
Ministry where is international law
there is no law says the uncle of one of
the
Dead nearby the Palestinian red Cresent
said one of its buildings was hit
injuring seven more it's in the same
place where Israel says it discovered a
network of Hamas tunnels adding more
fuel to its Relentless military campaign
we'll apply maximum power with maximum
Precision everywhere that's
needed that promise extends Beyond
Israel's borders in Beirut funerals for
three senior Hamas officials took place
Thursday the men were killed in a
suspected Israeli air strike
hamas's Ally in the region Hezbollah has
vowed Revenge raising the risk of a
second front and a regional War the fact
is there are a lot of people who are at
the edge of doing something very violent
and with all those troops with all those
guns pointed at each other we could
stumble into a war in the Middle East
that is the fear of Israel's closest
Ally the United States which dispatched
its Secretary of State to the region for
a a fourth time Anthony blinkin is
expected to push for calm and for more
Aid to gaza's besieged civilians without
explicitly calling on Israel to stand
down we want to see them do more to
reduce the impact on the civilian
population and to and to protect
innocent lives they believe that they
still have a viable Threat by Hamas that
the Israeli people are still under a
threat by Hamas in this increasingly
tense moment some Israeli government
hardliners have suggested removing
palestin Ian from Gaza entirely
statements decried as irresponsible by
the
US those words are fueling more anger in
a region already on the brink Jackson
prco Global News
Washington the Islamic state has claimed
responsibility for yesterday's bomb
attacks in Iran that killed dozens at a
memorial for a former General the twin
blasts were originally said to have
killed more than a 100 people but
Iranian officials have revised that
figure to 84 in a statement Isis said
two of their members detonated explosive
belts in the crowd Iran's leaders called
the bombings a terrorist attack and
promised a harsh
response a US drone strike in central
Baghdad has reportedly left four people
dead including a senior figure in an
Iranian linked militant group reuter's
news agency says six people were also
wounded in a strike the Iraqi government
has condemned calling it no different
from a terrorist act and flagrant
violation of Iraq's sovereignty the
Pentagon confirmed the attack saying it
was quote necessary and proportionate
action against a group that was actively
involved in planning and carrying out
attacks against American Personnel in
the
region Brawl on the bench coming up a
Las Vegas Court reaches the boiling
point
[Music]
a brawl broke out in a Las Vegas
courtroom as a man charged with violent
assault vaulted over the bench just as
the judge was sentencing him to jail the
man was wrestled to the floor and is now
facing multiple new charges the judge
and a sheriff suffered minor
injuries more than 80 people are now
confirmed dead from Monday's powerful
earthquake in Japan and though the
likelihood of finding survivors is
fading Rescuers are still searching the
rubble this footage released by local
police yesterday shows Rescuers pulling
an elderly man from a collapsed building
in the city of suzu he'd been trapped in
his home for 44 hours tremors are still
hitting the area raising concerns about
further damage and
landslides Sweden is in the grips of a
record-breaking cold spell temperatures
plunged below - 40° in the northern part
of the country the coldest January day
the country has experienced in 25 years
the military had to be mobilized to a
freeway in the South to rescue drivers
Stranded by heavy
snowfall strep a on the rise in Canada
the serious risk just
ahead Health Canada has has given the
green light to a second vaccine for RSV
fiser as B veent vaccine will Target
those most at risk of severe infection
from the respiratory virus it is
authorized for Canadians 60 years and
older as well as those who are pregnant
in their final weeks fiser says it's
committed to Bringing Supply into Canada
as quickly as possible in the midst of
respiratory virus season doctors across
the country say strep a is also making
the rounds for the most part cases are
treatable but as Katherine Ward explains
there can be serious risks if
infected managing coughs sore throats
runny noses and headaches are common
symptoms especially during the winter
doctors say group a streptococus could
be the culprit it's pretty common when
you think about strip throat but
invasive group a streptococcal
infections commonly referred to as eye
gas can be deadly that the CV infections
the invasive strap a infections remain
rare but we certainly see a trend
towards increasing cases Health Canada
says an early snapshot suggests disease
activity in 2023 is higher compared to
pre-pandemic years particularly in
children under 15 years of age in 2023
Nova Scotia reported 94 cases the
highest number in 5 years Pei also saw
an increase reporting 28 cases mainly in
adults in Alberta there were 739 cases
compared to
434 the previous year because the data
is tracked by calendar year some doctors
say it may not capture current ey gas
Trends group a strep does not
necessarily have a seasonality except in
the setting of it being a serious
secondary infection on top of a
respiratory virus that does itself have
a season and we're right in the middle
of that season right now towards the end
of December the BC Center for Disease
Control issued a notice about cases of
ey gas on the rise in children after two
deaths were reported Dr Brian Conway
says those deaths involved compounding
factors the two cases that occurred that
led to the the death of the children was
an initial respiratory infection with
influenza that was particularly severe
and on top of that there was a secondary
infection with a bacteria group a
strepto caucus or group a strep that
unfortunately led to their demise
infectious diseases Physicians say strep
a can often be treated with medication
and the most important thing to remember
is to seek medical help if symptoms get
worse Katherine Ward Global News
Toronto the highest score next how a
teenager beat what's supposed to be an
unbeatable
[Music]
game Microsoft is making the biggest
change to its computer keyboards in 30
years by adding a button for artificial
intelligence known as the co-pilot key
it will launch an AI chatbot when
pressed to help with a variety of tasks
the button is expected to be on new
Microsoft products as soon as February
and will sit to the right of the space
bar well for the first time ever it's
believed someone has beaten the game
Tetris the feat was achieved by a
13-year-old boy more than three decades
after the game was released so what does
beating the game mean exactly
for the teen who did it you could say
everything fell into place Abigail Bean
explains have you been tetr sized the
simple building game of falling bricks
Square rectangle trapezoid texures of
has captured hearts and Minds Tetris
challenges the mind and buzzles the
imagination and popular culture the
Chevrolet Traverse offers 44% more
maximum cargo space for decades this is
what all those hours of playing Tech TRW
for now a 13-year-old has our fingers
itching
[Music]
again oh my God Willis Gibson Who games
by the name of blue scooty is believed
to be the first person to beat Tetris
his screen froze I can't feel my fingers
he basically got to the point where the
game had no more memory to actually run
anymore and at which point the game just
crashes and and basically just ends the
accomplishment is RO in the gaming world
all my feeds is just like the same thing
like everyone's going crazy he already
had three milestones in this one record
so it's wildly impressive just the fact
that he reached level
157 I think is honestly absurd Philip
ing is one of the best Tetris players in
Canada he says Gibson's age doesn't
surprise him more and more young people
are playing with great success I had
already thought the limits of the game
were already reached and this shows that
there are new heights that have yet to
be reached what's more surprising the
game finished was Tetris designed to
have an end no the tetris is not
supposed to have an end so the fact that
they got there is yeah it's a kind of a
miracle it's poetry art and math all
working in magical synchronicity it's
it's the perfect game his story turned
into a Hollywood movie last year Hank
Rogers is responsible for bringing
Tetris out from behind the Iron Curtain
still fast friends with the Russian game
designer over dinner Wednesday night
they marveled at the 13-year-old this
kid is amazing I mean like what an
accomplishment uh you know this game was
released in 1991 like how many years
before he was born is
that though at a reported 20 hours a
week Roger says he's not so sure he'd
let even his own son play his game for
so
long I'm going pass out Abigail Beman
Global News Auto
way to go Willis and that is global
national for this Thursday night I'm
Carolyn Jarvis tonight's your Canada is
Golden British Columbia we love seeing
your Canada please email your photos to
viewers at
global.com thanks for watching hope
you'll join us again tomorrow night have
a great
[Music]
night